okay let's do it let's let's let's have
the product Jordan this is what we have
to do we have to do a quick commercial
the sponsor now is Lady crackers oh yes
why don't you just give an ad for lady
crackers right now just make it up as
you go lady crackers Los Angeles olive
oil and sea salt now you're going to
often find lesser quality oils used in
many products things like soybean oil
these are industrial oils then you'll
find seed oils sunflower safflower
rarely do you find a brand that's
willing to go to the expense of
providing a premium oil because frankly
most consumers don't understand what
they're putting in their body they
shovel food in they don't understand the
quality of said food now you have a
product that is using olive oil one of
the finest oils on Earth can I just
confirm can I confirm hold stop for one
second can I confirm Frank he had no
idea what I was going to hand him no
idea this is not written there's no copy
there's no copy this is Absol what are
you doing how do you able to do that
well the first thing I I look for a
product made with olive oil and lack of
seed oils or processed oils like canola
which is also called rape seed which
people perceive because it has a high
monounsaturated fat content did you say
grape seed rape seed but don't talk that
way on this program what are you talking
about that's
awful that's a piece of Flora
nevertheless I look for products that
don't use processed or seed oils I like
certain kinds of fats I like olive oil
butter uh or ghee coconut oil is fine
let's get back to you know the sponsor
is going to want to hear their product
name and a little more about the product
rather than a list of every oil that
exists lady crackers Los Angeles olive
oil and sea salt premium very few
ingredients which is always a good thing
would you like to taste one why don't
you open it up and taste one uh it's
okay I I uh could you please I typically
try to avoid yeah it's okay you please
avoid please yeah just open it and when
I open a box like this I don't I like to
keep these three tabs intact okay
sometimes it's a challenge if I have to
look I believe that we're defined by
what surrounds us aesthetically every
day I like a beautiful looking box to
around me a box that I could picture you
especially if we're producing a program
like this ripping this thing open like a
gorilla but uh I like to uh delicately
sticks in your mouth right just have the
cracker please yeah I
understand yeah well uh what do you
think it's not overly salted that's a
good thing you know sometimes they put
too much salt on they put too much salt
oh 340 milligram that's a little high
preserving I don't know how you def a
serving size 1 o that's a sponsor Jordan
so just try and be positive about it is
that to say that it's a perfect product
who am I to who am I to assess this is
the worst ad ever you can't just crunch
what I'm saying is I I see a lot of if
you're looking for a cracker if I were
looking for a cracker if I found myself
a lot of people look for crackers in
their daily lives they feel like they
want a cracker if I wanted a cracker I
would certainly go for lady and Larder
that's a fine pitch I'm going to do you
one better lady and Larder I want a
cracker at night and I want one with a
clean
crunch that gives you that lady and
Larder crackle the munch crunch that
makes you happy a whole bunch that's why
Lady and L lady and L tear that box open
rip them tabs and slam that Cracker down
your puss and remember if any crumbs go
astray use your tongue get it outside
your face and lick them up keep that
tongue out outside your head it's a good
way to get those crumbs lady and L now
with more of the good stuff that you
love get it
now what do you think good ad well you
know we have different approaches yeah
you talked in a very depressed way for a
while and they said seems like kind of a
high sodium content in the end we both
appreciate lady uh crackers for
different reasons yeah you like the
clean crunch I like the lack of
overreliance on processed industrial oil
it's the clean crunch that gives you a
Munch and I love it a
bunch see the way it Rhymes people love
that in an ad they're not going to
remember your sodium content quip but
they're going to remember
M do you have an idea for a jingle for
this do you want to sing a little song
about yeah the company asked us to to
sing a jingle can you please do the
jingle I'm not one to sing but uh I
could tell you I wrote a jingle for
Guinness beer once I entered a contest
in 1996 and I believe I one so the they
may have this regular you had to write a
limmerick you're familiar with a
limmerick oh that's racist but sure yeah
and I have I live with a leprechaun okay
and I just ate a fourleaf clover for
lunch a limmerick is a written work that
follows a very specific syntax and
rhyming structure okay five lines one
two and five rhyme and then three and
four rhyme okay Guinness had a contest
come up with the limmerick and the
winner will get maybe it was a trip to
Ireland or something like this so in
1996 I sent an a Limer which I have to
believe would have
remember I absolutely remember it I
can't wait to hear it and I'm and the
fact that it didn't win tells me that
either they lost the mail or or someone
didn't the right person didn't look at
it right what's the limmerick okay
here's the limmerick about Guinness
beer across ey a young traveler set out
on a quest to find Fortune no doubt as
he strolled into Enis he was pulled a
cold Guinness hence the lad's pot of
gold was that
Stout you know what that's good yeah
that that's very good and I spent a long
time on it oh I hope you didn't spend
too long on it but well I want to know
what was better than that I'd like to
know Guinness in 1996 what was a better
liyi than that to promote your product I
got no acknowledge there was an old man
from Man
Tucket who wanted his young friend to
suck it he said Guinness I said I didn't
mean your head and then the guy kicked
the
bucket I just made that up that's pretty
good and you know what I spent no time
on it yeah and it's got something dirty
in it so everyone's going to remember it
yeah I feel mine is superior okay but
the point
is uh don't you're still bitter that you
lost that Guinness okay I don't need
Island I'd like the recognition what was
the prize I believe it was a trip to
Ireland I I can't confirm some PR I
don't drink beer myself my family fled
that
place let's get out of here there's
nothing to
eat you're referring to the Potato
Famine no my people fled in
1982 the line at Burger King was too
long we got to get out of here let's get
to Brooklyn Mass they flew over on Air
Lingus
um her Lingus that'd be a Funny Elmer
also dirty Hey listen uh I thought you
did a good job with the
ad